So,
uh,
the book is called the sentient
machine and it really is,
um, uh, varied book. You
know, it starts off with, um,
some philosophical ponderings on what
the advent of Ai really means for us.
There are,
as you know,
some existential concerns regarding the
advent of more and more powerful Ai,
uh,
Agi.
And then Asi and lots of very worthy
scholars have written volumes,
uh, about these, for example,
Nick Bostrom's superintelligence,
which I'm sure many of you
have heard of if not red.
And then beyond that, there's
also discussion around, uh,
essentially these two fears that
keep sort of a rearing their head in,
in different ways,
but one that AI will take away all our
jobs and it might render us useless when
it gets to a certain level
of complexity and capability.
And the other is that it might kill us.
And of course that has many different,
um,
aspects and,
and situations under which that
fear manifests itself. But, uh,
in a nutshell,
those are two real conversations
that are happening these days.
And for this audience,
I'll also tell you that these are not
just hypothetical or philosophical
quandaries.
And questions anymore.
They are now being played out at the
highest levels of government. Uh,
so spark cognition works
in three principle areas,
national security industry
and Energy and finance.
And as a concept, and I won't talk
much about our own work, this is,
this is a talk about the book.
This is not a talk about spark
cognition on my work per se. But, uh,
because of that background,
I ended up meeting with and having some
pretty interesting discussions with,
uh,
the senior most military leadership,
not just in this country
but also for example,
in allied states in Europe
about two weeks ago,
I addressed the NATO counsel on their
adapt Taishan a report that was about to
come out and how,
believe it or not,
AI will play a great role in the new
adaptation report that was just released
based on the writings
that a general John Allen,
who's my collaborator and also on
the spark cognition board and I, uh,
published earlier this year.
So that's just one example to say that
artificial intelligence is becoming real
in many,
many ways and perhaps in
narrow domains initially.
But the capabilities are widening.
And for some of these existential
concerns that people have expressed,
um, for example, that
it will take jobs away.
Realize that we don't need commander data,
Agi level capability for those
sorts of things to be threats.
Eni Capability implemented in many
different areas can lead to 30%,
40%. God knows what percent
unemployment remains to be seen.
And that's for developed countries.
On the other hand,
for undeveloped countries
or developing countries,
they have invested a lot in there,
a burgeoning what they call their
demographic dividend. You know,
people that have been brought
out from, uh, conditions of, uh,
sort of, uh, you know,
underprivileged and are now being educated
and are being made available to do
complex tasks in the economy.
Well,
some of those complex tasks might be
subsumed before those generations get an
opportunity to really make
a mark. So there's that, uh,
emerging sense of the fallacy of the,
uh,
burgeoning middle class in developing
countries and whether they'll be able to
play the role that we once thought
they would be able to play.
We don't know. We'll see. At what
rate these technologies progress.
But my point here is that all ready,
we are at a point where the discussion
around artificial intelligence is partly
technology, but it's
also partly policy. And,
uh, in my own case, I've tried
to bring these things together.
And in the book you see, uh, the science,
the philosophy as well as elements of
policy because ultimately we have to do
something about this. Um, and I'll tell
you later on as we get into this, uh,
for example, some of the discussions
around bands and autonomous weapons,
I've been quite deeply involved in all
of those debates and have, um, met with,
uh, a lot of folks that really do
matter in that, in that debate.
So we'll, we'll go through that. Um,
the way I would structure the talk is
I'll start off with a very brief reading.
Uh,
and you know,
the beginning of all of these sessions
ends up being different just based on
what chapter you choose. So here we
were talking about autonomous weapons.
Maybe I'll start with, uh, the beginning
of a chapter called warfare in Ai.
Um, and then we'll talk about more
broadly some of the content in the book,
but I've also structured a presentation
that takes us a little bit beyond the
book.
There are some concepts here which for
accomplished computer scientists that are
in the audience might seem
to be very basic and you,
you may be familiar with them and I'll
go over those quickly if they become
boring, but then we can get into
some of the other issues. Um,
and some of the problems that
I think we still need to solve.
So that's how I'll go.
And of course I'm open to
questions at any time and comments.
I would welcome that.
Okay.
So for those of you who do
have the book on page 87,
I'll start with a very brief
reading of this chapter
is titled Warfare and Ai.
Join me for the thought experiment
originally published in the U S Naval
Institutes Proceedings
Journal and conceived off by
my friend and collaborator
General John Allen of the
United States Marine Corps,
a four star general and pass deputy
commander of US Central Command.
It is January two 2018 and a captain is
contemplating damage to his ship after a
surprise attack. This however,
was no ordinary attack.
He is about to discover that this was a
massive widespread strategic surprise.
Our captain and his crew
had not anticipated the
incoming swarm because neither
he nor his ship recognize that their
systems were under cyber attack.
The undetected cyber activity
not only compromise the sensors,
but locked out defensive systems leaving
the ship almost entirely helpless.
The kinetic strikes came in waves as a
complex swarm of drones door into the
ship.
It was attacked by a cloud of autonomous
systems moving together with purpose,
yet also dynamically reacting
to one another and to the ship.
More than anything, the speed of
the attacks stunned and overwhelmed.
The sailors though the ID
specialists on board the ship,
we're able to release some defensive
systems from the clutches of the cyber
intrusion.
The rest of the crew simply did not have
enough decision making time to react
mere seconds.
And in these few seconds,
some of the sailors ascertained with
their limited situational awareness that
the enemy's autonomous cyber and
kinetic systems, we're collaborating.
But in a matter of minutes,
the entire attack was over.
The captain survived and
courageously remained on the bridge,
but he was badly wounded.
As we're,
as much of his crew fires were burning
out of control and the ship was already
listing badly from flooding because of
the damage the captain was unable to
communicate with the damage control
assistant who was herself badly wounded.
It appeared that some of the autonomous
platforms knew exactly where to strike
the ship,
both to maximize the damage and
reduce the chances of survivability.
The captain's ability to command his
ship was now badly compromised and the
flooding was out of control.
After surveying the entire situation,
he realizes he must make a call that
no American skipper has made for
generations.
He issues the order to abandon ship.
Okay,
so going through this,
um,
you might wonder if this is a fiction.
It is.
You might wonder if this is entirely
imagined fiction with no grounding in
truth. It is art. Um, it
was very interesting, uh,
this past year I had the opportunity
to travel through the Middle East.
And as you know,
there are many numerous active conflicts
going on in the Middle East and many of
them are conflicts that are
taking an asymmetric, uh,
sort of, uh, uh,
tilt where you've got somebody like the
who theories as an example in Yemen or
you've got isis terror organizations and
Syria and some parts of Iraq and you've
got then on the other
side for the most part,
well armed military forces
with sophisticated radars
and Patriot missiles and so
on and so forth. And um, let
me just tell you that, uh,
I know for a fact that much
of what is described here,
maybe not with this level of nation
states sophistication, you know,
because here what we described is a swarm
of a improvised you calves coming in
with pretty sophisticated vision and
other recognition capabilities going
forward.
Well-Protected asset,
but similar scenarios have actually
played out in the current conflict in the
Middle East.
The DIY AI improvised
flying IED is already here
two weeks ago.
Uh,
the Convention for Conventional Weapons,
which is a little awkwardly named,
but CCW at the UN got together I think
for the third or fourth time over three
or four years.
And they're 107 member states
of this organization and the UN.
And every year they've gotten together
and expressed their dire concern over the
potential spread of autonomous weapons
and what they must do. And of course,
you may remember the famous what's
called the Elan Musk letter,
which was really not Elon Musk's letter.
It was the most recent one was
written by Professor Toby Walsh, uh,
from the University of New
South Wales in Australia.
He's an AI professor there. And of
course, Elon Musk was a signatory,
and then the letter was presented
as a desire or a request for a band,
which it was not.
It was a request for a discussion.
And at the end of this
most recent session,
107 countries even get together after
four years of debate and agree on what the
definition of an autonomous weapon is.
In the meanwhile,
the clashing cove bureau,
which many of you may have heard of,
which is the Russian weapons manufacturer
announced that they were testing a UGV
and unmanned ground vehicle,
which in field tests had already
shown better than human performance.
Now, you may doubt these claims.
You may think these are oversold,
but wait a year or two.
Similarly,
China announced that they were fielding
AI powered cruise missiles and the Mig
bureau announced that the new next gen
meg aircraft would have AI autopilot
operating, uh, to control the flight
envelope at hypersonic speeds.
So this is just one vignette.
This is just one side of Ai,
which is it is a technology that brings
or distributed autonomy at large scale
to the field of battle.
It is a strategic level up,
if you will,
in terms of capability
and no significant player,
no significant military is
going to ignore this. Uh,
and just to give you
further evidence of this,
of the hundred and seven countries
that were at the CC w session,
there were only 22 that came out and said,
uh,
we are in favor of a ban
of all the nuclear states.
There was only one which supported the
band and of all significant militaries in
the world, all states with
significant militaries in the world,
only to supported the band,
the largest militaries,
the countries with the largest number of
nuclear weapons all argued for further
discussion.
Let's push this off to next year.
So that's where we are. That's just
one vignette. But with that, uh,
let me start talking about sort
of some of the things that we,
that we cover in the book.
So what's quite clear to me now is that
we've made enough progress in several
areas where a new form of
intelligence really is coming. I mean,
it's no longer sort of the
wizard of, uh, the wizard of Oz,
a man hiding behind the curtain.
It's no longer just large numbers
of if then else statements.
And while we keep uncovering every
now and then company x and company y
outsourcing some activity that
they call intelligent Petrolia,
it's going out to uh, you know, the uh,
Amazon Mechanical Turk type situation.
Really aside from all of those things,
intelligence in an increasing level
of intelligence is being built.
And we've had,
with deep learning in particular,
we've had great impact on perception
tasks. You know, where we want to,
for example,
classify,
we want to perceive something and extract
complex patterns and even patterns
across the moral boundaries.
We've been able to do that very well
with deep learning and now we're sort of
running forward with reinforcement
learning with lots of new innovations.
And, uh, the, the,
the key thing to take away there is where
moving from the domain of perception
to the domain of action and even
within reinforcement learning,
now we have the ability to um,
train systems up maybe in simulated
environments and with some of the break
break break throughs that are taking place
and transfer learning. We take the, uh,
learning that's done in a simulator and,
and translate that to the real world.
So this is not a talk about the current
state of the art in all three of these
areas,
but just a couple of minutes to say that
this is becoming quite real and indeed
a new form of intelligence
if not sanctions is coming.
Sanctions I think is far
away. Um, so with this,
just a quick background, uh,
one of the things that you know,
I think I do differently in the book
is simply a consequence of my own
background.
So I'm a serial entrepreneur and I've
been based in Austin and I went to school
at ut Austin computer science and have
done a number of software companies since
then and spark cognition a,
it was a company I founded back
in mid 2013 the company focuses,
as I mentioned on national security
finance in industry. In fact,
we are a Google partner on a
number of different things and,
and the company's grown
really, really fast. In fact,
it's the fastest growing company in
Austin. Now with that being said,
that's the business side of things,
right?
How you actually take this technology
and make it work and make it solve
problems for the largest
companies in the world.
But the other side of this is that I
come to this not just purely from a
business background.
I am a computer scientist by training.
I love computer science. I
love computer science. And, uh,
I serve on the board of advisors of ut CS,
which is one of the great,
uh, really pleasures, um, when I'm,
when I'm able to spend much time there.
So it brings sort of the business aspect,
the practicality of making these things
work with the science and attempting to
advance the science.
And then finally,
the center of new American security is
one of the premiere think tanks in DC.
And I serve on their advisory
board for artificial intelligence.
In fact, about two or three
weeks ago, I was in DC. We were,
we had a scene as conference on AI and
what this would mean for autonomous
weapons. And there were lots of generals
and a serving and otherwise and,
and many, uh, policy
policymakers in the audience.
But we also had Eric Schmidt there. And
a, I had an interesting discussion with a,
with Eric and one of the topics
that came up was, well, uh,
how long given the China just
announced their 20, 30 AI plan,
which many of you may have seen,
it's an investment of $150
billion of government spending.
Uh, over the next five years. In 2015,
the u s government spent one point
$1 billion on AI. And in 2016,
we spent a whopping one
point $2 billion on AI.
Again, the Chinese government has
committed just governmental spending,
$150 billion over five years.
And if you read the 2030 AI report,
it says by 2030,
we will be the dominant AI player.
In addition to that, they also talk
about all the applications of Ai.
And a big chunk of that
is military application.
So here we were in DC at this conference
and I asked Eric, I said, Eric,
um, you know, I have a
view, but what's your view?
How soon do you think China will be
able to overtake the U S in Korea?
I capability?
And it's on video and then they will a
lot a lot of articles written about it,
but he said five years,
I don't disagree with them,
it sounds very aggressive,
but the rate at which progress is being
made, the rate at which, um, you know,
just if you look at face plus plus send
the rate at which they're improving
their vision algorithms. And a few years
ago I remember people used decide, well,
you know,
AI papers and China show,
they are publishing a lot of AI papers
but they're not as good as good as us.
Well now that's really
not the case anymore.
And it sort of reminds
me of the whole, um, the,
the reaction that we've had too many other
countries that have been catching up,
it probably just copied it. Oh, it's kind
of like a fake, uh, you know, sort of,
kind of there, but it isn't the
same thing. And then suddenly,
very quickly you realize that,
that folks are catching up.
And where we are in our current situation
as a country is that we're doing
things like preventing the spouses
of h one B immigrants from working,
which means that fewer smart
people will be able to come in. Uh,
we're trying to ban entry from
a number of countries and uh,
limiting the number of smart people that
we'll be able to bring into the u s so
while you have a near peer competitor
putting a 150 billion to your 1.2 billion,
you're also then strangling,
uh,
some of the core elements of a innovation
that have historically been so useful.
A useful for you.
That I think is a bad timing.
So moving onto another element
in a lot of these stocks,
people ask just the simple question of,
well,
what does it mean for a machine to think?
This is obviously a very complex
question and there's many,
many different ways in
which a machine can think.
And we tend to describe things
in the context of a neural,
where you take a neural network,
you give it a lot of data,
and then you can ask it a question
about what you've trained it on.
And it leads to classify
or in a regression sense,
give you some sort of an
answer. But I figured that
from a visual perspective, no,
there's many ways machines can think
and AI isn't just machine learning.
There's many other things in
AI as well. Uh, for example,
a search based optimization.
So here,
one way that you can think in a problem
domain is let's just take the simplest
example of tictactoe. Uh,
given just a couple of rules.
You can pre generate all the possible
outcomes and then what is perceived by the
human player to be a smart move is simply
a goal seeking behavior where I know
what a win looks like and I've
generated the tree or the graph.
And I'm trying to traverse the graph to
find the most efficient path to what I
know to be a win.
And that's one way in which you can
make machines, uh, appear to think.
But we also know that not every
problem has such a small state space.
So there are problems.
I mean even games taken other game
like Batman where uh, you know,
whereas miss pacman quite at this moment
and how many of the golden nuggets have
been consumed and what's the
direction of each one of the photos?
And did you eat the berry or not?
I mean,
there's a lot of variability
in that state space.
So that's the kind of thing that you
wouldn't want to just encode in this way.
So then now we try to do things like a
reinforcement learning where this start
off and start playing the game and you
end up and you've die pretty quick,
but maybe you made 50 points and what
you are trying to remember is what
sequence of tasks got
you to those 50 points.
The first ones that you took are pretty
much worth the 50 points because they
lead to you getting the 50 points.
But as you move further
along in that stack of moves,
you realize that the closer you
get to 50 the less valuable.
Each one of those more recent
moves were because goddammit,
the last one got you killed.
So that can't be very valuable.
And so you can have this sense of, well
let me feel, and there's again many,
many different approaches to this,
but you can have an element
of randomness to where,
let me try and get the maximum reward.
But when the level of reward
goes below a certain threshold,
I'm going to try different things and
maybe I find something that's more
interesting. So this is sort of
like a self pruned search, you know,
in reinforcement learning
and just layman's terms.
It's sort of like a self pruned search
where you start off with something and
you don't abandon that, but you just
look for improvements where you can,
you can find them.
And we've seen great progress with this.
Now another thing that I will
point out is that even in this, uh,
idea where you are generating
entire states, by the way,
stuff that's not fashionable
people stop thinking about.
But there's a lot of problems that can
be smartly pruned to where these sorts of
solutions are still pretty good solutions.
I mean you don't hear
a star search much now,
but if you apply data properly to a
star search and you come up with clever
heuristics on how to prune what gets
generated and what gets searched,
there's a lot of problems that you can
solve pretty cleverly with a star search.
But anyway, uh, in this particular
case where you see the full tree,
one thing to note is that generating
the states sometimes can be incredibly
simple. Can, that's one concept
that I'll build on here. So here,
what you had to know to generate this
whole tree is that for every progression
you can only change or add
one symbol at a time, right?
So if you've got knots and crosses,
either it can be, uh, you know,
you can add one not or one cross,
you can't add two knots in one go.
Um, you need to know what the
winning state is and that sort of,
we all know a diagonal or line or
a horizontal bar. And then with,
with every step here, as you
step through the tree, um,
in every layer you are
alternating symbols.
So first you get a knot, then you get
across, then you get a knot and so on.
That's all.
That's all that you need to know in
order to generate something like this.
And so, uh, is that, you know,
sort of this mind altering fact in
the context of knots and crosses?
Not really,
but it does go to say that very,
very simple things when
iterated upon when,
uh, when, uh,
dealt with with recursion can create
tremendous complexity that can be useful.
Okay.
So a seed of specification can,
can create something that
is very, very large, very,
very useful and sometimes
a little unexpected.
These are concepts that at
least in two different places,
and we know we talk about the game of
life briefly in the sentient machine,
but, uh, what I cover is just
the basic introduction. Uh,
Stephen Wolfram,
who's the creator of Mathematica and
somebody that I followed for many years,
very interesting thinker in his book,
a new kind of science.
He spends,
you know,
almost 200 pages just
going over different forms,
different variations of the game
of life. And these, again, if you,
how many of you are familiar with the
game of life? All of you. Okay. Almost.
Uh, and so again, these are
really, really very simple rules.
And what from shows is that you can have
these incredible levels of complex non
repeating patterns that come from very,
very basic rules.
Uh,
and other sort of more in lines of sort
of a continuous mathematics is this
notion of, of fractals. And there's two
things that I wanted to quickly say.
So one, uh, since you are
familiar with the game of life,
I'm sure you've seen simulations
like this, but to me,
every time I see stuff like this,
I'm amazed, you know, it's a,
there's these creatures would
like distinct behavior that,
that evolve every time.
And they,
some of them find stability and
others oscillate between two states.
And then you have some movement.
You have this, uh, you know,
artifact called a glider that just
sort of walks across diagonally.
Usually you have these
blobs that can combine.
And then what comes out of
that is at least not visually,
immediately predictive.
And these can be very complex sort of
behaviors. And looking at that, you know,
does seem to be like there's
something going on here.
And of course we know what's
going on here is just very simple.
Three simple rules.
But the manifest complexity is far
more than those three simple rules.
Uh, an initial reading of those
three simple rules would imply
the same as the case really when you
start thinking about fractals because, uh,
I mean this one is the Mandelbrot fractal
and Belvoir Mandelbrot came up with an
expression, which is Yay long. I
mean, that's it, right? That's the,
the amount of math that's being
generated into the structure.
And the reason why we're going
into this is that a, I mean, again,
for those of you who've read Ender's game,
the book and not the movie,
uh, you'll, you'll,
you'll realize or recognize or remember
that there's one comment in there that
was made where ender was at this training
facility and he was given access to a
large computer and somebody pulls him
away and says, what are you doing?
And he says,
I'm traveling through the fractal.
And now the fractal is larger
than the known universe.
So when I read that as a teenager,
it sort of stuck in my head.
I don't think that when the book was
written that computers had actually
generated a fractal that was larger
than the known universe, but now, uh,
that have many examples of this.
So to think that this much math,
this much specification,
this much code can generate something
with unending complexity that is a
unpredictable actually, uh, and
unique at so many different levels.
Um,
to me is pretty amazing.
And the two ingredients of that of
course are the specification and the
iteration and the recursion.
And that gets me to one of the points
that I make in the book also about the
universe being computable in a
different way. So you've heard, um,
Elon Musk recently talk about how the
universe might be a simulator actually
came across that concept of in my youth,
a gentlemen by the name of Ed,
Fred Kin had written extensively on this.
And then when I started digging
deeper, I realized that Conrad, sir,
even back in the forties,
had talked about these concepts and add,
Fred can, um, you know, this
article my father gave it to me.
It was published in a magazine whose
God is the universe of computer.
And the idea there was not
so much Elan's mosque idea,
which is that we're all
living inside the simulation,
which is one type of simulator inquiry.
But the other idea was,
is the universe fundamentally computable?
Like everything we see,
is it a consequence of computation?
Many years later,
my sister became a string theorist and um,
I tried to get, uh, at least, uh, uh,
a workable understanding of string theory
and my many conversations with her.
And one day she sort of lost a
patients with me and said, listen,
all of what we write in,
in words in English,
it's just a sort of 0.2
roughly in the right direction.
If you want to understand any
of what we are really saying,
you have to work through the math.
None of this really translates in, uh,
in,
in language.
And the one thing of
course from string theory,
which is very interesting, is the, the,
the rediscovery potentially of
what the Greeks called the atom,
you know, ah, Tom, that
which cannot be cut.
They were in search of that final
particle that was truly in divisible.
And perhaps with the Planck length,
it's not so much the particle,
but it's the fact that we know how
small a particle can be. We have,
if the universe is Minecraft,
we know the smallest size
of the Pixel of the block,
right?
Within which there can be nothing else
other than just one symbol contained.
And what does that symbol, that symbol
can be a configuration of a string.
So in that sense, I started
thinking, well, if that's the case,
then you essentially can
model the universe as a data
structure that has these
fixed size cells that are
planned class size cells,
which have a number of
these, uh, symbols in them.
And in that sense, it's
computable, right? So who knows?
Lots of different people are thinking
about this in different ways. Uh,
Max Tegmark has his book. Uh,
and he talks about some of this,
uh, of course, ed, Fred, Ken
and Conrad Zeus, or like I said,
have been thinking about this
for many decades. Um, and, uh,
Stephen Wolfram has his take on it,
but there's something here.
There's something here about the fact
that computational constructs on very,
very small,
um,
recipes can create this sort of
a useful emergent complexity.
And now as we know, you know, computers
can create computational realities.
I can today basically build my own world.
I start the book off by saying that I
got into computers because at the age of
four I ran into a commodore 64.
I saw hang man laying on the screen and
it blew my mind because I had never seen
a TV screen play out what
I wanted it to play out.
And yet there was a keyboard which I
could touch and suddenly everything was
fungible. This notion of programmability
for a four year old mind was,
was completely mind blowing.
And from there it went to, well,
what can I not create?
And now of course we know we can
pretty much create what we want.
And even the physical dimensions of all
of this are not gated in any way by by
reality.
These are some just fundamental things
from computer science that we ought to
realize that, uh, the, the basic
constructs of computer science,
the magnification,
it'll constructs the iteration,
the recursion and so on and so forth.
Applied to very basic
specifications can yield a lot.
And then if you start thinking
about the mind of a machine,
which any such,
uh,
thinking is partial because we don't know,
we, you know, there's a lot to be done.
There's a lot of questions to be answered,
but think about things just in
terms of differences with us. Well,
one thing we know pretty well is that,
you know,
our brain fits into a relatively small
cranium and consumes about 20 watts.
It's very, very efficient. It has
a very large number of neurons.
It has a very large number
of connections. But, uh,
for all of its efficiency and size,
etc. It's not really substantially going
to consume more than 20 watts in its
present form.
Um,
while we don't have a computer
that's as efficient as a brain yet,
we do know that our computers can
consume much more than 20 watts.
They don't have to sit inside a physical
cranium. That's the, the size of ours.
Uh, perfect recall, which is that,
and this is interesting because you know,
we tend to sort of live in the moment.
We get what we need from that
experience and we tend to forget.
And in many ways this is good for us.
It's good for us actually
because it avoids overload.
And this is common with
another thing that we do,
which is very aggressive pruning.
So we tend to go down certain solutions
and we tend to discard things that sound
ridiculous to us.
So the reason why that move that Lisa
Dole and others found so magical,
even all the commentators that were
great practitioners of go was because it
just was one of those things that
they were willing to discard.
Nobody's done this before, I've never
done this before in this situation.
Why the hell would you ever do this
before? It becomes sort of common sense.
It becomes the kind of thing that is
system one thinking in a few go back to
[inaudible] and his
teary about how we think,
thinking fast and slow and
we start pruning things.
But in machine intelligence can actually
be in a place, can take everything in,
can learn what it can at the time,
but the original experiences
entirely preserved.
So if its ability to extract
more knowledge from that
experience improves over
time. The original data and full
fidelity is still available. In fact,
uh, my colleague, Professor Bruce Porter,
who's the chairman of the ut computer
science department is working on a long
running project that
does something like this,
which is that he's developing machine.
Um,
so natural language understanding software
and he's been working in that area
for 35 plus years.
And his approach is that what I can't
understand what my current algorithms in
the corpus will get
tagged in a special way.
And every iteration of the algorithm will
go back and look at what the previous
iteration was not able to understand.
So this sort of constant learning with
the availability of the fully preserved
information. That's not how
we usually think about things.
We filter out a lot of stuff.
And then of course there's other
things like being disembodied.
I mean there's no need to
protect a physical a body at all.
There's no need to comply
with a size limitation.
And of course we know about the
faster processing. So, uh, you know,
the question here is if human beings are
devolved with an eye also on the back
of our head, would we be
fundamentally different? Probably.
Probably.
I mean,
a lot of the Amygdala driven response
that we have now in situations of fair
where, you know, uh, we,
we are aware that there could be something
pretty close behind us that's got to
keep us,
uh,
that could get us and therefore we have
to keep at a high state of readiness.
Well, uh, maybe that we
would be less, I'm neurotic,
you know, with an eye at the
back of our head. Who knows. Uh,
so these are all the kinds of
things that, of course in, um,
machine intelligence,
we get to experiment with.
One other element, very practical element
of what's happening right now, um,
is, you know, so,
so we're talking about AI of the future
and the mind of a machine and so on.
But what's happening right now,
you know, and in the valley,
everybody knows,
Marc Andreessen said awhile ago that
software's eating the world and that sort
of a euphemistic thing. But for me it's
a, it's a very real physical thing.
So this is, uh, you know, traditional, uh,
combustion engine and you've
got an electric motor onto
the right hand side and
you've got valves and, and, uh, uh,
spark plugs and efs and carburetors,
and you've got a block and you've
got all of things going on here.
And each one of them
has a specific function.
Each one of these mechanical elements
performs a specific function.
And then you've got an electric motor
where most of the capability of the
mechanical elements has been transformed
into software. The Efi, for example,
how you gate energy is now all software.
So the reduced number of physical
components in that picture on the right is
when you subtract that from
the picture on the left.
That is the amount of physical stuff
that software just eight. Okay.
And there are similar pictures like
this across a whole host of areas.
We work very closely with Boeing.
Um,
I can tell you that
the future of aviation,
even though it's not
going to be very imminent,
but Boeing's invested in a company that's
doing electrical engines for proper
commuter aircraft.
You're not the size of a triple seven yet,
but you know,
multi seat commuter aircraft,
short haul a electric,
that changes a lot of things.
If you look at what companies
like [inaudible] he hang
hangar doing the Chinese
company, he hang with autonomous
drones. Uh, the city of, uh, um,
actually the country of UAA appointed
an AI minister recently and they've
expressed their,
their desire to build the world's
first autonomous flying a taxi service.
And they in fact even signed a contract
with a Chinese company and they're now
looking to move that to somebody else.
But they are committed to doing that.
So these things,
uh,
even in the narrow context are
happening and uh, the, they're,
they're certainly coming to, to, to bear
last point here I'll make and then we
will kind of stop for questions. Um,
important thing is not so much,
uh,
whether AI will do everything.
The important thing I
think is what all can a,
and I do in a given period of time.
And if you look at the right there,
that's a study that was done recently,
a poll. Many AI experts and
you may agree or disagree with
those and some of them may be optimistic
and some of them may be pessimistic,
but for example,
the ability to assemble any lego
right in the next 10 years or so.
Now we know that when you can assemble
any Lego, you're not just assembling Lego.
It's a fairly general purpose capability
that you have a manufacturing robots
have been increasing in huge ways.
If you look at warehouse management just
five years ago and what we have now in
terms of warehouse management capability,
it's tremendous.
And nobody's going to want to discuss,
you know,
the poetry of Robert Froster roomy
with a warehouse management robot.
But it is going to take a, it is
going to have an impact on, on jobs.
And so part of what my uh,
push really has been a particularly
on the policy side has been, look,
we hear it all the platitudes that uh,
you know,
people say the machines are coming,
the machines are coming,
but really it's like any other revolution.
It's like any other
technological area of progress,
era of progress rather where there'll be
new jobs and all these people that are
displaced here,
we'll find things to go do there.
And I think that's just complete hogwash.
I think that's nonsense.
I think the two things that we've done,
one,
we've replicated human
muscle with the steam engine,
which basically we got ourselves out
of every job that requires a muscle.
And now by replicating, not the entire
mine, but even parts of the mind,
slivers of the mind that are good
enough to form a, to perform a function.
We are at a point where we can automate
much of what we do in, in many,
many professions.
And that's all we are.
We are muscle and mind. I mean
that's what, that's what it is.
So there's no third thing to go
and replicate. And with this,
the impact may not be us
in Barka loungers you know,
Allah, Wally, but it might
be 30, 40% unemployment.
And who needs to start
thinking about this?
The people that need to start thinking
about this are the people who make
policies. And there are some
countries where, for example,
they've gone and they've
started experimenting with
them. Uh, things like, uh,
you know, a minimum wage of
essentially minimum guaranteed income.
Um,
there are countries like France,
which are progressively reducing the
number of workers so that automation can
pick up the slack and people
can get time back. I don't know,
Bill Gates has proposed a tax on robots.
I am not proposing a specific solution,
but what I am saying is that the level
at which this discussion is happening
with the
inevitability of the
impact right ahead of us.
I think that level of discussion is uh,
in significant and insufficient.
And I started the stock
about, uh, you know,
talking about autonomous weapons and
sharing with you the rate at which the CCW
UN is making progress on even
defining what an autonomous weapon is.
While at the same time autonomous
weapons are being deployed.
And here again,
we might find ourselves in a,
in a situation where more and more
automation will make it into factories,
into retail spaces.
Uh,
we're working on an engagement with a
large company in Dubai to do concierge
intelligence based on natural
language processing in retail stores.
It's going to start off being
interesting and sort of like a,
you know,
how do you get people in into the shop
and you would track them with something
that's a new and shiny, but it'll get
pretty good pretty quickly. So, uh,
that's kind of where we are in my,
my hope is that we can,
with all of the work that we're doing
and all the conversations we're having in
Brussels and DC and
elsewhere, is to get, uh,
the leaders of our nation and frankly,
the leaders of the Western world to take
notice and to truly focus themselves in
developing policies that can sustain
this AI powered world of the future.
So with that, I'll stop, um,
see if there are any questions.
Thank you for your, uh, your talk. Um,
my question was mostly about
like, you know, the ending,
the last thing you talked about,
right? Um, I often hear about,
um, the need for more discussion
policy, policy changes, right?
But it really alarms me because when
you see the kind of discourse that our
elected representatives often have about
even like really basic technological
issues, you realize they have no idea what
they're talking about. Right. And like,
it really worries me when they might
be having discussions about things like
this, which are potentially
very complex and nuanced. Like,
is there a solution to this? Like, you
know, you, you mentioned even that like,
you know,
they're having discussions about defining
things that are already happening,
right? Like, what, what
can we do about this?
That's a very difficult question.
I think one thing that we
should do is to not give up.
So what I'm personally doing,
uh,
is that I try to the best of my ability
to insert myself into every forum where
I can impact policymakers,
where we can go and share the story and
explained to them the quantum of impact
that is coming. Uh, two weeks ago I
was speaking at the Texas CEO Summit,
which is an economic summit.
So they talk about how the state's growing
and what the future of work will be,
but you have leaders, the state
leadership, economic leaders,
and so on present day. And I taught that
what I said may have been surprising,
but it was well received. People
were willing to listen. Um,
I brief pretty much everyone
at the Pentagon. Uh, and uh,
I told you I met with Eric
Schmidt. Uh, you know,
that was also in connection
with a seniors event.
So that's the one thing I know how to do,
which is to be out there and keep
repeating the message over and over.
And then as a consequence of doing that,
you find allies,
you find kindred spirits
you find in an exchange.
I didn't know how Eric was
going to answer that question,
but he happened to answer that question
in a way that supported the basic thrust
of what we were talking about.
And that became 25 media articles,
you know, uh, General Allen,
I recently wrote in foreign policy that
got reprinted in the national newspaper
of the UAE. It showed up in Canada,
showed up everywhere. So again,
we got forced change physically,
but what we can do is influence
huge numbers of mines.
And in doing that we can find allies.
You know, this is a mind shift.
So I don't expect people that have no
grounding and no interest in this area to
suddenly see the light.
But I do hope that we'll be
able to find around them,
influencers and shapers that can at least
carry the day and move them forward in
the direction that the country, the
world needs them to move in. It's a,
it's not an easy process and it's not a
direct answer but that's the best I know
how to do.
Thank you.
I the title of the Book and the talk
is the sentient machine and we haven't
talked much about
sentients. Yeah, right here.
But that is a goal of many of the teams
working towards this self aware machines
with morality and ethics of their
own real viewpoints and perspectives.
Now that might be five years away,
40 years away,
but it would be a good idea to have some
kind of idea of how to deal with that
when it gets here before it gets here.
So in the circles that you talk in,
is there any discussion
about ways to manage,
regulate and interact with
AI other than as property?
That's a very good question.
And by the way,
I completely concur with your original
observation that the title of the book is
the essential machine in this stock.
We didn't really get into what ascension's
and so on. The book does cover that.
My view of it. And just to
give you a very quick, uh,
sort of response to that
in my view, uh, you know,
intelligence and a lot of people
agree with this, but not all. Uh,
intelligence is about goal directed
behavior and the larger your goals,
usually the more intelligent
we assess that entity to be.
And dummy sanctions is a combination
of intelligence and self awareness.
So what I talk about
in the book is sort of,
I think therefore I am that school
of thought of the principal,
um,
proof even to myself that I exist
is that I can externalize my,
my myself and then observe
myself thinking and then say,
Aha, I must be. And then
from there we go. We go on.
But that being said, um, you
know, your question really is, uh,
whether in these practical,
you know, domains,
whether, um, there's a realization, uh,
that so,
so the trust of your really
is managing sanctions or, uh,
not the, not creating sentients in
these machines. So there is nothing,
no. So the government manages
and interacts with people, right?
But the government does not manage
us as though we are property. Right.
All of the talks that I've heard
are about managing ais property.
Are there any alternative talks going
on that you've observed? Yes. I mean,
I'm part of that alternative doc myself.
What I say in this book is that
even if you go back to our, uh,
religious traditions,
not to take them literally,
but if you go back to
our religious traditions,
what made Adam great was the fact that
he could take action on his own and up
until the creation of Adam in our
Abrahamic system of, uh, religions,
uh, the angels et Cetera, could do just
what they were told to do. Uh, and the,
the fact that Adam could do what he,
what he wanted to was what made him great.
If we now are after millennia
and millennia of evolution,
poised at the juncture where we can
be the kind of creator that can create
something that has its own with
two whatever limited degree,
because we haven't figured out
how much free will we have,
but to whatever limited degree, I don't
think that that's an automatic, um,
uh, you know, a dampener on, on this
process. And I don't think we should stop.
I also think there's a long ways to go,
a lot to learn.
There's a lot to do with ethical systems
and safe AI and so on and so forth. So,
um, uh, a new form of, of life.
If it truly is sentient, should
we treat it as property? No.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I have another question.
Uh, in your book, um, you,
you talked a lot about,
um,
opportunities and dangers of AI
in all sorts of different aspects.
And again,
I want to encourage everyone to read
the book because it covers so much more
subject matter then,
uh, this darkening, uh,
one of the things they found the
missing was, uh, when you, um,
write about mine hacking,
um,
both on like on a personal level
and on a national level, right?
Is there any like solution that,
that you see,
like how to defend against that?
Like sort of like an antivirus that will
say your mind is being hijacked or your
democracy is being hijacked?
Yeah.
Yes.
Uh,
so in the book there's a section called
AI shields and that talks about how,
uh, you would want to use, uh, AI, uh, to,
to fend off that kind of Ai,
uh,
because basically what's happening
now is that we will know once this
investigation into the Russian
involvement in an outer
election is full liter veal,
but a tens and tens of thousands of
bots were using very simplistic NLG
technology. Do not just retweet, but
come up with messages that were targeted.
And the indent was to shift the prevailing
sentiment in the, in the election.
So, uh, we've developed systems,
others have developed systems that can
look at that kind of generated activity
and a identified as distinct from
what somebody actually wrote.
And even otherwise,
looking at the pattern of post behaviors
and profiles and so on to detect what
is might be a very sophisticated part.
But ultimately this is sort of a, uh,
um, you know, sort of, uh, a
cycle. They build a better bar.
Then you've got to find out ways to
detect that better bought and so on and so
forth.
But I think that is very critical.
The other thing which you may like or
not like given that this is Google, uh,
is in my view,
there's too much control
of Algorithms in the cloud.
I think that, uh, just just
to give you the very simple,
basic example is that I
want to control what I see.
I've made a conscious decision now
that it is not good for a social media
service and I won't name any specific one.
All of them do this for a social media
service to decide what they want to show
me, regardless of how good their
machine learning algorithms are.
And regardless of how good
the collaborative filtering
is and regardless of what
they think my cousin likes or
what my younger brother, you know,
clicked on yesterday.
Um,
I want to be an active participant
in the filtering of my feed.
And in fact,
what I would like is I would like
all of my posts from my network,
totally raw feed and on my end I get
to decide what I want to see and what I
don't want to see. If we don't do that,
we're in trouble. And if we don't do that,
then you know, US engineers and
builders, etc. Should go to that.
Um,
I think having this notion of your
own AI shield and your own AI filter,
that's very,
very important.
Having the convenience of multiple data
centers all over the world and having
the convenience of not having to buy
and configure computers and having the
convenience of being able to get to
them from any point, uh, you know,
on the world. Uh, is one thing,
but then also not controlled.
Not even knowing what the,
today I can't even tell what the hell
the raw feed is that I'm supposed to get.
There's just no way to get to that.
It's such a glaring omission.
That to me is ridiculous.
And I think that's another area where
the algorithms need to be controlled more
by us.
Even if the cloud platforms
provide the data and now to say,
Oh, you know, don't worry,
you don't have the compute power to
filter your own feet. Nonsense. Come on.
That's how many,
how many posts will I get in my feed?
10,000 a day. I could probably do
that on her ass, but he buy, you know,
so all of us can do that, Frederick. So
the technical arguments no longer apply.
It's a control argument and it's very
important to let people manage the
information the way
they want to manage it.
So in the last slide where
we talk about a lot of STI,
the loss of jobs and
those jobs potentially not
replaceable as has been in the
past. Uh, see there, there's sort of the,
the muscle where you're,
you're talking about labor moving to
steam engines and those innovations at the
factory innovation that came out of it.
But nowadays the first level of AI
implementation that we are looking at like
self driving cars.
So in some ways they seem sort of muscle
plus plus there is a little bit of
intelligence on top.
Where do you see that heading to in
the next 10 to 20 years where uh,
that muscle plus plus really
becomes as capable as,
as an infant's mine for example.
And what will be the impact of that on
unemployment. So there's, if you can,
um,
if we can look into the future five years,
10 years and maybe even 50
years and see where we end up at
in terms of AI researcher directions.
I'll answer that question in two ways.
One of the things that I'm actually very,
very curious about and have been very
curious about for a long time is this
whole idea of intrinsic motivation,
hierarchical reinforcement
learning and intrinsic motivation.
There are many challenges with this
because I mean ultimately if you, if you,
if you, if you say this
simply, it sounds simple,
it's not very simple to go do,
but the idea is,
well you can have a
reinforcement learning pickup,
one task and then you can have it pick
up another task and then one can be the
sub task for the other end.
So you can have this hierarchical tree
and if you keep building all these tasks,
then you'll have a pretty
big coverage. But the, the,
the challenges with that is whether you
can really do that and whether you can
have these independent tasks and so on.
And second, it's intrinsic motivation.
That's another topic that
I do cover in the book. Um,
Andrew Bartow wrote about this
father of reinforcement learning.
Andrew Barber wrote about this as well,
but that is a,
where does that flame come from?
Where does that,
so when you talk about
a three year old child,
to me it's not so much that we can't build
a machine that does what a three year
old child does lift the amount of weight
or can be driven to where a three year
old child can be driven in that
very mechanistic kind of sense.
The thing about a three year old child
is that that three year old child is born
with a flame.
And that flame of intrinsic motivation
is something that we need to figure out.
Actually, some people have
hypothesized things like, well,
you know what that flame really is, is uh,
emergent. And I talk about that in the,
in the, in the book as
well, emergent purpose.
I went looking in philosophy
for what that purpose is.
Somewhere along my life I thought
I knew what I was supposed to do.
And then one day I felt,
what the hell am I supposed to do now?
And so I started reading
philosophy and you know,
at that point I realized that,
you know,
even even people like Camou Alphabet,
the French philosopher and writer,
he said things that were, you know,
the existential, the Hilus movement.
He said things like, well, uh,
that leap of faith is,
um,
philosophical suicide,
intellectual suicide because you,
you accept that there came a time when
your knowledge couldn't take you over the
humps. So you just assumed, in other
words, you did away with that gift,
which was your biggest gift.
So I don't know whether I'm that extreme,
but I do think that that,
that internal flame,
that intrinsic motivation would
still be something that's missing.
I think narrow systems that have,
uh,
not a flame,
but a set of criteria that they
are going to go and optimize.
You'll see that much of,
I mean,
all of our system one type stuff,
you can pretty much mechanize.
And now if you look at
your day and you say, well,
how much system to type stuff too?
I do. Uh, depending on who you are,
it's going to be variable.
But I think for a lot of jobs,
the job itself is a lot of system
one stuff, and that then goes away,
three year old child, everything.
Other than that intrinsic motivation,
I don't think we have an answer to
that. Intrinsic motivation. Thank you.
Thank you so much. I'm
here. Thank you very much.
[inaudible].